Foods marketed as healthy are actually making
America fat.
If you don’t want to know more, I suggest
you run away now, for about 30 minutes a day
with an elevated heart rate.
Actually, you should just do that anyway.
Hey gang, Matt Lieberman here for DNews.
Obesity is, dare I say, a huge issue in the
United States.
Nearly two thirds of US women and three quarters
of US men are overweight or obese, and a new
report published in the journal JAMA Internal
Medicine revealed that Obese Americans actually
outnumber overweight Americans.
It’s big news, but a new study published
in the Journal of Marketing Research is weighing
even more heavily on my mind.
The study, authored by the American Marketing
Association, shows that foods marketed as
fitness, diet, or healthy options can lead
to overconsumption and actually reduce consumers’
motivation to exercise.
The study examined the eating and exercise
patterns of so-called “restrained” eaters,
who are chronically concerned about their
body weight and image.
Participants were allowed to choose between
two bags of trail mix, one labelled simply
Trail Mix, while the other was labelled Fitness
Trail Mix, with an image of running shoes
visible on the package.
They were given eight minutes to eat and give
their opinions on the trail mix of their choice,
and then encouraged to exercise as much as
they wanted on a stationary bike.
Overwhelmingly, participants who chose the
Fitness trail mix consumed more of it and
also opted to work out far less vigorously
than those who chose the “normal” trail
mix.
Through simple marketing, people internalized
the message that this trail mix was a light,
fit snack, and that exercise was therefore
less necessary or not necessary at all.
However, diet foods are in many ways just
as unhealthy or more unhealthy than foods
considered unhealthy.
You see, when food producers try to make a
food seem leaner by cutting fat, they often
add sugar and sodium to make it taste as great
as the real thing.
Take breakfast cereals for example.
Cereals like General Mills’ Total Raisin
Bran, Kellogg’s Smart Start, or Kellogg’s
Low-Fat Granola all contain more grams of
sugar per serving than a powdered sugar donut
at Dunkin Donuts.
All of their boxes encourage a health-conscious
lifestyle.
But if a consumer decides to eat more in one
sitting AND exercise less often, their sugar
intake could skyrocket.
What’s worse, it’s not just an American
problem.
In the UK, the University of Hertfordshire
discovered that foods from 7 major supermarkets
marketed as healthy options for children in
fact contained more sugar, fat, and salt than
the same healthy foods marketed towards adults.
Either way, we’ve got a mega-sized marketing
mix-up here.
In closing, don’t be fooled by a pair of
running shoes, a happy sun, or pictures of
happy, rugged hikers.
Always read nutrition facts and the ingredient
list of foods before you buy, and hey, it’s
better to eat less of the real thing than
to eat more of a processed clone.
And hey, if you want to see more of me, why
don’t you check out this fun video on Sourcefed,
where I talk about the Pizza Hut Hot Dog Stuffed
Crust Pizza?